why learn languages that's a question I
get all the time why even bother you
know you're an old man do something else
is that all you got to do in your life
find something better to do curiosity
humans like to learn we spend our whole
life learning things we are built to
learn we have become what we are today
because we are eager to learn because we
are curious about things we don't all
have to be curious about the same things
we don't all have to learn languages I'm
not saying that it's a better thing to
learn but there are a lot of benefits
and the big thing about learning
languages it's fun to me it doesn't have
to be to everyone to me it's fun to
learn it's fun to discover things
through language it's fun to meet people
through language bottom line it's fun
and it satisfies my curiosity